la desinformación vuelve a entrar en
Campaña en Brasil a un mes de las
elecciones generales minimizar las
noticias falsas sigue siendo uno de los
objetivos elementales para las
autoridades que aunque están hoy mucho
mejor preparadas que en 2018 todavía
deben controlar millones de contenidos
que inundan sin filtros las nuevas
plataformas sociales
ha habido cambios para combatir la
desinformación en estas elecciones
respecto a las anteriores la justicia
electoral ha creado por ejemplo una
comisión de seguimiento permanente para
evitar la difusión de información falsa
con un grupo compuesto a día de hoy por
más de 100 profesionales de las más
diversas áreas
Hace cuatro años los comicios estuvieron
empañados por la difusión masiva de fake
news especialmente por WhatsApp según
expertos aquello tuvo un impacto
importante en la victoria del
ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro ahora se
buscan a contrarreloj más mecanismos de
control
definir es necesario la justicia
electoral defina un procedimiento
simplificado para recibir las denuncias
evaluarlas retirar el contenido engañoso
de los medios de comunicación y
sancionar rigurosamente a los
responsables
desde el Tribunal Superior electoral ya
se ha ordenado la eliminación de varias
decenas de contenidos la mayoría de la
campaña del actual mandatario una
cuestión todavía preocupante
[Música]
desde las últimas elecciones que fue
cuando ganó bolsonaro el tema de las
fake news se ha hecho mucho más fuerte
precisamente por la campaña de nuestro
actual presidente y es muy preocupante
de verdad porque creo que mucha gente lo
eligió con base en varias fake news
varias informaciones sesgadas que él
mismo transmitió a la población
por el momento plataformas como WhatsApp
han restringido la creación de grupos
hasta después de los comicios más
polarizados en décadas en los que el
expresidente Lula da Silva continúa
aventajado en la contienda cerca de 15
puntos porcentuales